>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Mari Nakahara: Hello, everybody.
Good afternoon.
>> Good afternoon.
>> Mari Nakahara: Thank you
for joining today's lecture,
titled "Washington, DC Witness
Tree" by Doctor Paul Dolinsky.
My name is Mari Nakahara,
the curator of architecture,
design and engineering
at the Library's Prints
and Photographs Division.
I also serve as a coordinator
for today's program.
The lecture is one of the 2016
National Cherry Blossom Festival
official events, co-hosted
by the Library's Prints
and Photographs Division,
Asian Division,
and the Asian Division
Friends Society.
I actually used to work at the Asian
Division as a reference librarian,
and I was asked by my former
supervisor to circulate this.
If you wish to become a member
of the Asian Friends Society,
please sign on and I
will just put it --
[ Background Sounds ]
Pursuing one of the Library's goals
of providing general understanding
of American culture, individual and
the social life and of other peoples
in the nation's, we
have been hosting events
and the programs related to
cherry blossoms since 2012,
when we celebrated the
hundredth anniversary
of cherry blossom tree gift from
the city of Tokyo to Washington, DC.
The library holds over
160 million items,
covering an almost universal range
of subjects in diverse formats,
including resources related to
cherry blossoms and their history.
The Library hosted Sakura:
Cherry Blossom as Living Symbols
of Friendship exhibition in 2012.
The exhibition and its gallery talk
and then also many educational
materials are still available via
the Library's website.
Although the scale is much smaller,
the Library again provides an
opportunity for the general public
to view the Library's historical
and contemporary images related
to cherry trees as a
[inaudible] case display.
In celebration of the National Park
Services' hundredth anniversary this
year, the display also includes
items related to national parks
and it introduces documents from the
Historic American Building Survey,
Historic American Engineering Record
and the Historic American
Landscape Survey,
which we call HABS, HEAR and HALS.
HABS, HEAR and HALS survive
through corporate agreements
amongst the National Park Service,
the Library of Congress and
professional organizations.
The Park Service creates
new documentation every year
which the Library preserves and
adds to the online collection.
The 2016 National Cherry Blossom
Festival is calling attention
to the benefits of parks and then
connecting more people with them.
The display was supposed
to be ready by today.
However, a little incident has
caused a delay in installation.
Once it's installed, I am hoping
within a week, it will be on view
until the end of June, so please
come back and take a look.
It's going to be on the
first floor of this building.
Please also note that
the Library has two
of a hundred remaining original
cherry blossom trees onsite,
which the Library's Public
Affairs Office confirmed
with the National Park
Service in 2012.
One of them is located right behind
of this building, near the corner
of the second street
and Independence Avenue.
Unfortunately the blossoms
are gone, but you may want
to stop by to look at it.
It is leaning on a
crutch, like this,
and it has a plaque,
so you won't miss it.
Before I introducing
today's speaker,
please note that this event is
being videotaped for broadcast
on the Library's website
and other media.
We encourage you in the
audience to ask questions
and offer comments during the
question and answer period,
but please realize that in
participating in the Q and A period,
you will be consenting to the
Library's possible reproducing
and transmitting your remarks.
Now I would like to introduce
today's speaker, Dr. Paul Dolinsky.
Dr. Paul Dolinsky has
long been associated
with historic preservation
in general and architecture
and in landscape architecture
documentation in particular.
Professionally trained in
architecture, landscape architecture
and architectural history, he
was uniquely qualified to work
with the Historic American
Building Survey, HABS,
of the National Park Service.
Dr. Dolinsky began to
work with HABS in 1979
as an architectural
technician working
with teams measuring
historic structures
and producing ink on miter drawings.
He eventually became
a project supervisor
and a national chief
of program in 1993.
During tenure as chief,
he instituted many changes
to the program, such as
computer-aided drafting,
[inaudible] distance-measuring
devices, photogrammetry
and additional laser
measuring as well
as significantly expanding the
historic research components.
During the 1980s, there was a
strong interest in the unique nature
of historic landscape architecture
with the cultural landscape
movement.
Dr. Dolinsky was instrumental in
developing a series of projects
that ultimately resulted
in the creation
of the Historic American
Landscape Survey, HALS, in 2000,
with the American Society
of Landscape Architects,
National Park Service and
the Library of Congress.
This rapidly-expanding program
has been extremely effective
in the last 16 years, now
having representation in 49
of the 50 states as well
as significant landscape
documentation American soil abroad.
Dr. Paul Dolinsky has been serving
and contributing as chief of HALS
since it was established.
Please join me in welcoming
Dr. Paul Dolinsky.
[ Applause ]
>> Paul Dolinsky: Those
are hard boots to fill.
My goodness.
I'm not sure if I know that
person, but anyway, Mari,
thank you very much for
that incredibly generous
and eloquent introduction.
It is quite a privilege to be here
today and I'm equally delighted
to see so many new faces but so
many familiar faces from my friends
in the Prints and Photographs
Division.
I certainly hope I can meet your
expectations and provide you
with some good information to
think about after you leave.
After Mari asked me to
speak, I considered many,
many different topics that I
thought might be interesting
for a more general audience,
and I quickly realized
that I'd possibly be
seeing a lot of yawns
in the room should I
proceed down that avenue.
So I finally settled on speaking
about something we all see every day
and how we might look at it through
a slightly different set of lenses
after you leave this room,
and more importantly,
have some fun during the process.
So, big surprise, I'm going to
talk about trees, but with a lens
of archival documentation in mind,
documentation to the standards
of the Historic American
Landscapes Survey,
or as it is more affectionately
known, HALS.
But before we can do that, I need to
briefly discuss its parent program,
the Historic American
Building Survey,
HABS, for some of the context.
By the way, in case you're
wondering, the photograph
on the front, the first slide there
is the view from the front porch
of Laurence Rockefeller's home
at the Marsh-Billings-Rockefeller
National Historic Site.
I think who would not love to be
sitting there during the summer,
but actually, like I said, we
will look a little bit at HABS
for some context and how HALS
was a logical progression,
if you will, of the HABS mission.
Not a very quick or easy task, but
bear with me through some leaps
of faith, because we only
have about a half-hour.
You can easily dig
deeper into either
and any of the three programs.
There is a tremendous amount of
published information about each one
of the them and how HALS was a
natural outgrowth, pun intended.
Sorry. And then we'll finally
focus on the HALS witness trees
of Washington, DC pilot project all
within the allotted half-hour or so.
As I said, to put HALS in
context, I really need to speak
about the Historic
American Building Survey.
Very briefly, it is a Roosevelt
administration initiative
under the aegis of the WPA to
provide temporary employment
for architects and
draftsmen unemployed
as a result of the Great Depression.
Like I said, volumes have
been written about HABS,
but for our purposes and
in the simplest terms,
it is one of the anchors
of our federal government's
preservation programs.
Hundreds of architects, draftsmen
and photographers were hired
temporarily for a four-month period
across the United States to produce
measured architectural drawings,
written history and large-format
photography of the complete resume
of the American builders' art,
and thanks to significant input
from the Library of Congress,
everything was completed
in standardized formats,
was to be durable,
reproducible and verifiable.
Why do this?
Well, the obvious reason
is of course
to employ the struggling
architects of the period
or at least provide them
some temporary relief,
but more importantly, the collateral
benefits of these documents turned
out to be far more than
an academic record.
In the burgeoning historic
preservation movement during the
1920s -- '26 is Colonial
Williamsburg, et cetera --
these drawings, history and
photographs proved to be invaluable
to provide existing condition
documentation as the basis
for restoration, insurance
needs for historic structures,
interpretative needs
and fundamentally
to maintain the resources
and the facility management.
I'd love to show you a
couple early HABS examples.
That one there, by
the way -- pardon me.
On top is the General Cowles
House in Farmington, Connecticut,
a wonderful neoclassical structure.
On the right is the large format
photographic, on the left,
the measured drawing, and
beneath it is the plan
of the ruin San Juan
Capistrano in California.
One of my very favorite
drawings in the collection,
this is the Le Pretre Mansion,
drawn in 1934, in New Orleans
and that wonderful photograph
looking from the balcony,
really illustrating the laciness
of that beautiful ironwork.
The success of the four-month
temporary relief was obvious.
It needed to be done on a
long-term basis and it was validated
by a permanent plan for
approval and disposition
of all future graphic records of
historic American architecture.
That is Gustav Rohrich standing in
front of his sod house in Nebraska.
There are very few sod
houses, I think, if any left,
and on the left side is --
right, left, is the measured
drawing not only of the house
but of the way the sod is
actually packed together
and how the house is actually built.
As Mari said a little bit about,
we exist through a
tri-partite agreement.
The National Park Services,
where I am based,
we administer and run the programs.
The American Institute of Architects
advises our professionalism
and makes recommendations for
documentation, and we're here
in the Library of Congress,
which preserves
and distributes our records.
It was made permanent and validated
in 1935 by the Historic Sites Act
as a regular duty of
the federal government.
The architects and landscape
architects employed during the
initial four months of the survey
recognized the significance
of historic landscapes through
a very small subset program
of the Historic American
Building Survey.
It was called the Historic American
Landscapes and Garden Project.
Unfortunately, its sun set after the
initial four months, but the benefit
of some of their documentation
will be very evident
in some of the slides we see.
This is The Lindens in
its original setting
up in Danvers, Massachusetts.
It now sits up in Kalorama.
You may know it was moved
here in the late 30s,
and it's currently for sale.
I think it's 8.7 million right now,
so it's gone up in price
a little bit, I think,
but this is a 1934 photograph
of this great 1754 Georgian
wooden New England mansion,
and here's the site
plan that was done
by the landscape architects
working for HALJP.
You can see the house itself sort
of enunciated a little bit darker
on the one side of it,
but there's the lawn,
the formal gardens behind
it and above, of course,
the vegetable gardens,
but the landscape architects dug
a little deeper and they produced,
on top, you'll see an evolutionary
drawing showing the home
in the 18th century and sort
of has it evolved up to 1934
on the upper right, and
then below, there are many,
many drawings of detailed
garden plans,
of every single flower,
every single plant.
They really dug in deep and did an
extraordinary job documenting this
house and garden.
This is another one of my
very favorite early documents.
This is the Captain Thomas
Bennett Sunken Garden.
You can see that sort
of sunken knot garden.
It's like a platter.
You step down into it,
surrounded by a hedge.
Very, very private, but the
elevations of the garden are tilted
up and to the left, and in the far
right, you see they even dug in
and drew the sundial in elevation
and plan and completely filled,
on one sheet of paper,
a complete document
of the Thomas Bennett Sunken Garden.
Another one of my favorites,
a magnificent 18th-century
Georgian gates and fence
at the Pierce Place in Salem, Mass.
This is about half a dozen drawings
of how these gates are put together,
with all the details, and then
of course the great photos.
Another very early landscape element
document, a folly, a garden house,
a summer, this great sort of Chinese
Chippendale little summer house
and a garden.
Beautiful photograph and
beautiful drawings, should you want
to build one in your own background.
I was always impressed by
this early set of drawings
of the Beau Caray in New Orleans.
That is a comprehensive measure
drawing of one entire square block,
every detail there, and then
the elevations of the structures
that make up the block
from the outside.
Cover a little bit
of geography here.
They were in Acoma in New Mexico.
Many, many drawings of
the great old pueblo.
You'll see a great aerial
photograph of the pueblo,
and there's just the first
drawing of the overall site plan.
Basically landscape documentation
continued as part of HABS from 1934
up until the mid to late 70s, when
there started to be more interest
in the documentation of
historical landscape architecture.
When I first joined the program --
I also have a degree in
landscape architecture --
I was asked to run a series of
pilot projects that would look
at what is different about landscape
architecture than architecture,
what is so different when an
architect looks at something
versus a landscape architect,
so we were asked to do a number
of pilot projects in the 70s.
The first major one was actually
more of an architectonic landscape,
but it's Meridian Hill
Park in Washington, DC,
that extraordinary
cascade of fountains
and the upper formal parterres.
The measured drawings, you can
see it's located directly north
of the White House, about 16th
Street, and there's a detail drawing
of it on one side followed by
about 28 sheets of other drawings,
but the important message here
is these drawings, histories
and photographs that were
produced ultimately informed sort
of the burgeoning cultural
landscape movement.
You needed this information,
you needed these types
of measured drawings, the
supporting research and photographs,
to inform the analysis and
treatment recommendations
for the preservation of these sites.
And here you'll see the Meridian
Hill drawings, and that is a copy
of the cultural landscape report
which is currently being used
in the restoration of Meridian
Hill Park, so in essence,
we were building the case of
the establishment of HALS.
All this ultimately informed
the establishment of HALS
and the landscape survey
because landscape architecture
is indeed unique.
So that's a lot of background
covered very quickly,
actually about 50 years of HABS and
another 25 years of HALS to get us
up to the present, and like I said,
we only have about a half-hour
or so here, so hopefully this
will intrigue you enough.
If you just search it on any engine,
trust me, you'll get a huge amount
of information, and I
encourage you just to go
to the Library's collection,
our collection at the Library.
It is staggering.
I think it's currently just shy of
45,000 sites or something like that.
It's been functioning
now 80-plus years.
So now, let's have a little fun.
I was musing over some examples that
might have influenced my thinking
in a less serious way, maybe
more of a popular culture way,
to explore HALS's documentation
of historically
and botanically significant trees,
linking together the historic
and cultural side of the National
Park Service with the scientific
and natural side of the
National Park Service.
We tend not to play in the same
sandbox, and they have a lot more
on the natural side, so we're
always struggling on this side.
So I'm always trying to find
money, to raise money for projects,
so this idea sort of coalesced.
Maybe we can figure
some way to use trees
to knit the two together a
little bit and have some fun
and do some serious documentation,
so I hope you'll recognize
this image.
It is the famous talking apple tree
in Metro-Goldwyn-Mayer's 1939
fantasy adventure The Wizard of Oz,
the tree encountered by Dorothy,
Toto, the Tin Man, the Lion
and the Scarecrow on their way
down the Yellow Brick
Road to Emerald City.
The Library of Congress has declared
this book America's greatest
and best-loved homegrown fairy tale.
I like to refer to this
particular scene as the vegan slap,
where the tree, in a very angry,
stentor voice says, "How would you
like to have someone come along
and pick something off of you?"
This particular apple tree
is not just a living thing,
but it could actually breathe
and speak, it actually argues,
and of course throws apples.
Or how about the remarkable
Swiss Family Robinson treehouse?
Every child's dream.
The romance of a treehouse, in
this case a treehouse on steroids
from the 1960 movie
of the same name.
Would I have loved to
have had that treehouse.
But indeed, my fantasy was realized.
A hundred and fifty-ton concrete
and reinforced steel Swiss
Family treehouse opened in 1962
in Adventureland at Disneyland,
and it only required a sea ticket.
The whole thing, though, was
recreated in 1971 at Disney World,
recreated in 1992 at Euro Disneyland
and finally again in Tokyo Disney
in 1993, a truly sort of
pan-cultural tree experience.
Or how about this one?
I don't know if you recognize
this one, the Whomping Willow.
It debuted in Harry Potter
and the Goblet of Fire.
It is a very violent
species of magical plant,
sort of a tree with
a mean personality.
Whomping Willows -- are there
any botanists in the audience?
I don't know.
I can't resist this.
It's a Salix whompus.
I couldn't resist.
It will attack anything
and anyone that comes
within range of its branches.
"We must not be hasty.
Things will go as they will,
and there is no need to hurry
to meet them," quoth Treebeard
from The Lord of the Rings.
Treebeard is the oldest of the
Ents still left in Middle Earth,
an ancient treelike being who is
sort of a shepherd of all trees.
He has a very tall and
stiff-limbed appearance,
with bark-like skin and leafy hair.
According to books, Ents are
much stronger than trolls
as trolls are just
crude imitation of Ents.
And last but certainly not
least -- I could go on --
the Tree of Souls from Avatar, the
source of all energy and light.
I'm not fluent in Na'vi, so I
will not dare attempt the correct
pronunciation, but it is a giant
willow-like tree that is a point
of extreme spiritual
significance to the Na'vi,
moreso than any other
location on the planet Pandora
for at least 3,000 years.
The destruction of the Tree of Souls
would prove devastating to the Na'vi
as a whole and would create
a cultural and religious void
that would decimate
their race entirely.
Such is the significance of trees
in our extremely creative fiction.
My mind really did
wander in that one.
I went to Paul Bunyan,
Johnny Appleseed.
There are a lot of opportunities
to sort of relate trees
in a popular way, but here are a
few quick examples of actual trees
that elicit and evoke similar
responses, very profound responses.
The redwoods at Muir
National Forest.
The sequoia of California and
Oregon are among the largest
and tallest trees in the world,
living for thousands of years.
John Steinbeck wrote about
redwood in 1961 in his Travels
with Charley in Search of America.
"The redwoods, once seen,
leave a mark or create a vision
that stays with you always.
No one has every successfully
painted
or photographed a redwood tree.
The feeling they produce
is not transferable.
From them comes silence and awe,
and it's not only their unbelievable
stature nor the color which seems
to shift and vary under our eyes.
No, they're not like
any other trees we know.
They are ambassadors
from another time."
Or how about the Avenue
of Oaks from Oak Alley?
The grand dame of the
great river road,
Oak Alley Plantation is a
national historic landmark located
on the west bank of the
Mississippi River in Vacherie,
the Saint James Parish in Louisiana.
Oak Alley is named, of course, for
that distinguished visual feature,
an alley created by a double
row of living southern live oaks
about 800 feet long and planted
in the early 18th century,
long before the present
Greek revival focal point
in the picture was built.
The alley or tree avenue runs
between the home and the river.
And finally, of course, to sort
of bring it home a little bit,
our White House Christmas tree,
the official indoor Christmas tree
of the residence of the
president of the United States.
Trust me, I came up with a lot
more popular culture examples,
but hopefully these will be
sufficient to drive home the point
of the role of influences
of trees in our society.
Probably it'll be a
little blurry out there.
Like I said, I was musing over a
way to connect the natural side
with the culture side of
the National Park Service,
and the idea of using trees
that have witnessed significant
cultural events coalesced
into the Witness Tree
Protection Program.
I hope you see a little
humor in that one,
but more seriously,
trees are landmarks.
They are memorials, they identify
us, they identify human happenings,
we love them and they carry their
associations through generations.
The idea of somehow preserving them
through documentation became
the core of the project.
The national capital region of the
National Park Service embraced it
and funded the project completely,
and we are off and running
and completed HALS's
documentation on 24 witness trees
as a pilot project for the nation,
and we'd like to show not all 24
but a few of them briefly and
sort of soak you in the idea
of what a witness tree is.
The Burnside Bridge American
Sycamore, Platanus occidentalis,
located at the Antietam
National Battlefield.
The Burnside Bridge American
Sycamore is a living monument
to those who fought there
on September 17th, 1862.
With over 23,000 total casualties,
the Battle of Antietam was not only
the bloodiest day of the Civil War
but also the bloodiest day
in all of American history,
and there you see a picture of
Union Army general Ambrose Everett
Burnside, with those
great mutton chops.
This tiny bridge played
a key role in the battle.
Burnside and the Federal
9th Corp had been charged
with first taking a stone
bridge spanning Antietam Creek.
Burnside's attack was delayed some
five hours behind the original
schedule, and when he
finally did attack,
the entrenched Confederates
repelled several charges
by concentrating their fire
on that narrow bridge opening
on the creek's eastern bank.
Burnside's force of
12,000 was held at bay
by a mere 400 resolute Georgians,
the brigade that held off
a corp. Standing beside
that bridge is another
historic feature known
as the Burnside Sycamore,
a witness tree.
The tree can be seen in photos by
the famous Civil War photographer,
in the lower right there, Alexander
Gardner, and over 150 years later,
it still remains as a direct link
to the story and to the past.
Or how about the Jackson
Magnolia, a magnolia grandiflora,
located on the south
side of the White House?
The Jackson Magnolia is a wonderful
hundred and eighty year-old story
of a tree that replaced itself.
This story started in 1829
when President Andrew Jackson left
his Tennessee home and journeyed
to the White House for his
inauguration and presidency.
Legend has it he had
a sprout from one
of his wife Rachel's
favorite magnolia trees.
At that time, though, he was
in mourning for his wife,
who had died just a few months
before his inauguration.
Taking a sprout of the magnolia
tree obviously had a strong meaning
for Andrew Jackson, and the majestic
tree has had a strong meaning
for many presidents since then
as well as their families.
Franklin Delano Roosevelt
and Winston Churchill
commented many times,
"We sat underneath that
old magnolia tree."
It's a remarkably durable
specimen and quite a survivor.
You may recall in 1994 it was
hit by a two-seat Cessna plane.
Hitting the south side of
the house, it hit the tree,
did some serious damage,
but it's still there.
And finally, to complete the story,
a cutting from the Jackson Magnolia
made a return trip to the Hermitage
to replace the original tree that
was destroyed by a tornado in 1998.
The War of 1812 Oak.
It's a majestic tree.
You can see the scale of it
next to those picked benches.
A Quercus phellos located at Oxon
Hill Farm in Oxon Hill, Maryland,
planted at least in the early 19th
century, possibly the 18th century.
The tree has stood
as a living witness
to a remarkable history
from the War of 1812.
This is a 17th-century tract of
land overlooking the Potomac River
and the future Washington, DC.
Ultimately it became known as Oxon
Hill Manor and its house is known
as Mount Welby, and that's
the view in the lower right
from Mount Welby toward
DC as it was burning.
The estate was situated near some of
the worst fighting of the entire war
and was in earshot of the Battle of
Bladensburg, and it was illuminated
by the fires in our capital,
and that remarkable willow
oak survives as a witness.
One of my favorites, the Fort
Hunt Park Royal Visit Pin Oak,
a Quercus palustris, down on the
George Washington Memorial Parkway
at Fort Hunt Park.
The Fort Hunt Park Royal
Visit Pin Oak is significant
because of its association
with the visitation
of England's King George the Sixth
and Queen Elizabeth in June of 1939.
The tree commemorates the visit
to the Civilian Conservation Corp,
the CCC, facility established
at Fort Hunt.
President Roosevelt and First
Lady Eleanor Roosevelt used
to showcase Fort Hunt as a model
facility for CCC and it played host
to a great array of eminent
foreign leaders, including future,
most prominent, the royal couple.
Two pin oak trees were planted
in honor of the occasion.
One of those trees still
survives today to witness.
The Lady Bird Johnson Park
Crabapple, a Malus species,
along the George Washington
Memorial Parkway.
Lady Bird Johnson Park is actually
a manmade 157-acre island located
immediately south of Theodore
Roosevelt Island along the Virginia
shore of the Potomac
River at the west terminus
of Arlington Memorial
Bridge and sort
of the symbolic entrance
to the nation's capital.
In 1901, the McMillan
Commission began to develop plans
for the present design
of Washington's city
beautiful, monumental core.
Less well known, though,
is the commission's plan
for a Columbia Island.
In 1932, the Arlington
Memorial Bridge
and the Mount Vernon Memorial
Parkway opened to the public.
The last phase of the work
on the Mount Vernon Memorial Parkway
project included seeding the grass
on Columbia Island and planting
approximately 75 ornamental
flowering trees.
A very few amount of
these crabapples exist
and this one certainly is a
mammoth example of a crabapple tree.
I think my favorite, the Frederick
Douglass White Oak, Quercus alba,
located at the Frederick
Douglass National Historic Site
in southeast Washington, DC.
Frederick Douglass, of course,
was one of our nation's leading
abolitionists, author, editor,
orator, reformer, statesman
and diplomat.
He lived at Cedar Hill.
He died there in 1895.
The Frederick Douglass White Oak
commanded a prominent location
in front of the property.
You can see it in the
historic photograph.
That same V in the branches exists
in the V in the large photograph
on the other side of the image.
It's located directly
outside his library
and witnessed his hours
of long work.
It was the largest remaining
tree in the property.
Sadly it has died and
has been removed,
the only remaining
archival record, of course,
being the witness tree
documentation.
The big daddy, Methuselah, the
willow oak, a Quercus phellos,
located on the George Washington
Memorial Parkway right near one
of the parking lots
near Belle Haven.
If you ever driven north on the
George Washington Memorial Parkway
from Mount Vernon, you more
than likely have enjoyed those
incredibly beautiful banked curves,
the landscaping, the views and sort
of the way the parkway
integrates into the terrain.
The George Washington Memorial
Parkway is actually the first
comprehensively designed
modern roadway built
by the federal government.
There's several things that
you noticed when driving
on it made it quite
revolutionary for its time.
You may have also noticed one
such curve, those gracious curves,
is gently interrupted
by sort of a hiccup
for no immediately obvious reason,
but if you go the desired
35 miles per hour,
you may have noticed an immense
tree located relatively close
to the road.
The National Park Service
staff affectionately referred
to this specimen, an immense
willow oak, as Methuselah.
Such respect commanded actually
altering the road alignment in order
to preserve the massive tree.
These mature trees, a Quercus
phellos, normally range in size
from 40 to 60 feet tall with a
30 to 40-inch spread on the crown
from about 110 to 220
inches around the trunk.
Methuselah's dimensions were
significantly greater than all three
of those, double some of those.
It's 160 feet across
the base of that tree.
Sadly, it was hit by a car
and I believe lightning
and has since been removed.
>> Oh.
>> Paul Dolinsky: See, that's
how much we love trees.
Indeed. But this of course is the
only remaining archival record.
Just a few more.
In Georgetown, the Tudor Place Tulip
Poplar, a Liriodendron tulipifera,
located in Georgetown, District
of Columbia on the great estate.
The tulip poplar is one of the
largest and most valuable hardwoods
of eastern North America.
Its spread is unbelievable.
It's from Connecticut and southern
New York to southern Ontario
and northern Ohio all the way
down to Louisiana and Florida.
It has a massive growth area.
This particular Tudor Place tulip
poplar is significant due its
association with the Peter family
of Georgetown and their development
of the Tudor Place Estate.
Tudor Place was designed by Doctor
William Thornton, same architect
that designed the large structure
across the street, the US Capital,
but this tree is an
absolutely massive specimen.
It occupies an extremely prominent
location on the south lawn.
Certainly among one of the oldest
tulip poplars in Washington, DC,
growing since the beginning of
property's long 200-year evolution,
and interestingly, Tudor Place is
the only private property protected
by a National Park Service easement.
Here's a local boy or girl.
This is the Union Square
Zelkova, a Zelkova carpinifolia,
located just at the bottom of
the hill here and Union Square.
The Botanic Garden elm is an
absolutely incredible ornamental
shade tree unlike another
any other tree on the mall.
It's significant because of
its rarity, its longevity
and its association with
the original United States
Botanic Garden.
It is also significant
due to its preservation
by Frederick Law Olmsted,
Junior, recognizing its uniqueness
in the world and certainly in
Washington, DC during his redesign
of the modern National Mall.
In 1820, Congress authorized
the Columbian Institute
for the Promotion of
Arts and Sciences
to found first the United
States Botanic Garden
on the site currently occupied
by Union Square at the base
of the hill, by the water,
by the big lake down there,
an area approximately ten acres.
In the 1850s, the first greenhouses
in the gardens were established.
This historic photograph
shows the conservatory.
It's about 300 feet long totally,
with a central dome
and two long wings.
The late 19th-century photograph
in the lower right-hand corner also
shows where the original location
of the Bartholdi Fountain
is, from 1877 to 1927.
It's now on the opposite
side of Independence Avenue.
The remaining Zelkova is a truly
unique specimen on the Mall,
as you can see by the photos.
I really would encourage
you to walk down and see it.
It's sort of right before the
street where the cross-street is
for the Native American Museum,
so memorize that picture.
And finally, the 1910 Japanese
flowering cherry trees,
Prunus yedoensis, located
unusually, in this situation,
on the East Potomac Golf Course,
East Potomac Park, Haynes Point.
You may all know that the history
of the famous flowering cherry trees
of Washington, DC begins in 1885.
A prominent city resident, a
travel writer and a photographer,
Eliza Ruhamah Scidmore
first traveled to Japan.
She was deeply impressed by the
beauty of the cherry blossoms
and the prominent place that
this flowering tree holds
in Japanese culture.
Upon her return to Washington, DC,
she lobbied Congress for 24 years
to plant those trees and
finally, in 1909, she decided --
she was almost ready to give up.
She decided to raise the money
herself and purchase the trees
and then donate them to the city.
She sent a letter explaining
all of this to First Lady Taft,
who embraced the project
immediately,
and this ultimately resulted
in a gift of 2,000 trees
on behalf of the city of Tokyo.
They arrived 1910.
To the great disappointment of all
parties, a United States Department
of Agricultural Inspection
team discovered
that the trees had some insect
infection, so the USDA determined
that the trees must be destroyed
and on the 20th of January,
President William Howard Taft
reluctantly gave the order
to burn the trees that his
wife had just helped acquire.
A second and even more generous
donation of an even larger group
of trees arrived in March of 1912,
with the first two trees planted
by First Lady Taft and Viscountess
Chinda the following day.
Those are the trees we know, and
now for the rest of the story.
It has long been assumed
that none of the cherry trees
from the 1910 shipment
survived destruction.
That's simply not true.
As we heard earlier, one of them
is here on the Library grounds
on the southeast corner, I think
it is, and the rest of them,
under recently discovered evidence
suggests that a small group of 24
of them were taken
under close observation
by government entomologists
for scientific analysis,
and today approximately
18 of the 24 survive.
They are very, very old
Yoshino cherry trees.
They're located on land now occupied
by the East Potomac Golf Course.
They are not only the oldest but
some of the largest cherry trees
in Washington, DC, but
they also survived more
than twice their expected maximum
age that's expected for the species
and they really have grown to an
extraordinary size, as you can see
by some of the photographs.
These witness trees are a living --
these 1910 cherry trees and the
1912 cherry trees are a living
and an enduring reminder of the
goodwill and friendship shared
by the people of Japan
and the United States.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
Thank you.
>> Mari Nakahara: Thank you
very much, Doctor Dolinsky.
It was wonderful.
I learned a lot.
We would like to hear some
questions or comments.
>> I was wondering, one of the
things I would love is a map
of those large trees on the capital,
basically [inaudible] them all, and,
you know, where you could have
like a -- guide yourself on a tour,
you know, and a lot of
them are like older.
Some are not.
>> Paul Dolinsky: Yes.
Anticipating that question, the
National Capital Region is going
to do a brochure flyer
of the witness trees.
Most of them are in Washington, DC.
Some of them are outlying,
like I said Oxon Hill Farm
and Antietam National Battlefield,
and some are even further.
The National Capital Region
has unusual boundaries.
So there will be a map
coming out from NCR
in the near future illustrating the
location and a brief history, too,
of each one of the trees as
well as, more importantly,
a link to the Library of Congress
so you can read the complete reports
and see all the photographs.
>> A question.
What is the replacement
policy when a tree dies?
Do you match it with
what was there originally
or do you put something new in?
>> Paul Dolinsky: I'm not uniquely
qualified to answer that question.
But in general terms, for example,
a good example would be the magnolia
at the White House that is replaced
from cuttings from the actual tree,
and there's another one been planted
on the grounds on the right side.
The original one's on the left side.
But in general terms,
that's an argument
that has been going
on for a long time.
For example, some large
plantations of formal plantings,
like an alley at the
Vacherie Plantation,
some of those were severely
destroyed around the Charleston area
and they left sort of a lot of
vacant teeth, let's just say,
in the middle of -- on the line,
so some people have actually chosen
to remove all and replace all
with similarly-sized new trees.
On the mall here, you will
see numerous replacements
of the elm trees.
One of the witness trees
is the Jefferson Elm,
which is actually the species
of elm that helped save us
from the Dutch elm disease,
and we're propagating that
and the new trees on the mall
that are replacing the dying,
expensive to maintain elm trees are
the same species, Jefferson elms.
Yes, ma'am?
>> Would you tell a
story or make a selection
of the Cameron Elm
on capital grounds?
>> Paul Dolinsky: Well, you
know, I don't know that story.
It's not a National Park Service
tree, but I'd love to learn more
about it and you know there's
no reason the capital can't do a
witness tree protection program.
Yes, ma'am?
Oh, sorry.
>> How do you actually
select the trees?
Is there like a list of criteria?
Do they have to have documentation?
>> Paul Dolinsky: That's
a very good question.
When I came up with this idea --
I mean literally, HALS
is a mendicant order.
You know, we always have to
go out and try to raise money
for these things, and
so I found the money
and by promising the
National Capital Region
that we'd use their
region as a pilot,
all of the National Park Service
cultural resource managers
in each one of the parks sent
in their recommendations,
and we gave them a
series of filters.
You know, a witness tree has, you
know, witnessed an historic event,
has to be, you know, botanically --
it has to be old, and
a few other things,
but approximately two
dozen actually came in
and we just did whatever
was sent in by the managers.
They understood quickly and
meaningfully what these trees were
and came up with a list,
and then we simply responded
to it and did the work.
Sir?
>> Thank you very much for your
great presentation, by the way.
>> Paul Dolinsky: I appreciate that.
>> Yeah, really good.
A lot of witness trees are logically
along highways and roadways
where things have happened.
[Inaudible] marched and [inaudible].
My experience of working
with Virginia's Department
of Transportation leads me to
understand that in this day and age,
transportation agencies often
view large trees like this
as too dangerous for them to be
maintained and in fact have worked
to -- some of the arborist
associations have come
up with a grading point system for
their removal based on the fact
that there's a large tree
near a highway with a lot
of traffic, it should be removed.
>> Paul Dolinsky: Yeah.
>> But I understand from other
arborists who were critical of that
that that's really an unfortunate
development because what's happening
around the country is older
trees which are witness trees
from the Civil War era and later --
>> Paul Dolinsky: Certainly.
>> -- are being removed by
transportation agencies based
on this erroneous view that a
large tree is too dangerous.
Does HALS do anything to
push back against that?
>> Paul Dolinsky: Well, we
have no bite in that sense,
and I will say the Department of
Transportation is sort of my enemy
in all historic preservation
projects.
They have the big money
and we have none.
But our documentation is meant
to, you know, somehow acknowledge.
Many of the houses or the
homes you saw are gone as part
of the Historic American
Building Survey.
I don't know what the actual
percent is of the collection,
but this is simply, you know,
documentation of the existing
condition and telling the story.
And I have to believe, because
I've seen it happen many times
with saving historic houses and
things, when HABS has gone in,
we've drawn the building, we've had
publicity, people tend to look at it
with a different set of filters
and then respect develops.
So ultimately, I think, you
know, maybe we can't, you know,
fight the Department
of Transportation,
but I think this program is making
at least the National Park Service
and I know a lot of other
private sector as well
as state programs acknowledge the
significance of historic trees
and document them, and I think that
it can only lead to the next step,
which is the respect and
potential preservation of them.
Yes, ma'am?
>> Do you know if there's
a landscape survey
of Yosemite National Park?
>> Paul Dolinsky: Well, yes and no.
There are portions of it that have
been measured in great detail.
For example, I just finished a
project documenting Curry Village,
but the park in total, no, but
discreet, the historic structures
and Curry Village and certain areas
have been done, but not in total.
>> Were you able to label
the Ahwahnee the Ahwahnee?
>> Paul Dolinsky: I just
knew you were going there.
I knew you were going there.
It's a bit embarrassing, isn't it?
They have a little, you know,
a shroud now over the sign
of the Ahwahnee and they've
renamed it something or other.
Our documentation uses the
original historic name.
>> Thank you.
>> Paul Dolinsky: Yeah.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Paul Dolinsky: Well, yes, ma'am?
>> I know that HABS, HEAR, HALS
in general propagate standards
for documentation and I'm
just wondering what --
I don't actually know.
What are the standards
for documenting a tree?
>> Paul Dolinsky: Very good point.
The standards fall back on literally
the standards established in 1933
and '34, and that is that
the documentation needs
to be durable, okay.
If there are measured drawings
being done, we will draw site plans
for trees and locations within
the site and that's durably done
on an archival vellum, usually
done with an archival ink.
In that sense, it has to be
-- the historical research,
of course, has to be verifiable.
That simply means footnotes.
Everything is formatted, in
that there are certain sizes
for the sheets of drawings, for
the sheets of historical research
and a format for the photographs,
so all those type of standards apply
when you're doing a tree.
You're photographing it, you're
researching it, you're drawing it
in a planned format or in some
other way, so the same apply
to buildings or engineering sites.
We simply, you know, think
outside the box a little bit.
Yes, sir?
>> This might have
been answered already,
but not every old tree
is a witness tree,
and how does one become
a witness tree?
>> Paul Dolinsky: I'm
not [inaudible].
Basically it's, you know, cultural
association with some sort of event.
It has to have -- you know,
the Burnside Bridge Sycamore was
there the day the battle occurred.
You know, Frederick
Douglass, you know,
was inspired by the white oak
tree out in front of his library.
It has a direct association with
the cultural and the natural, okay.
Sir?
>> Thank you for that.
That was a great presentation.
>> Paul Dolinsky: Yeah.
Appreciate it.
>> And I actually have a
question that's specifically
about cherry trees.
Are there any entities in
Japan that are interested
in how they're doing
and current things?
Because I know that we're
really good at documenting that,
but I've always wondered,
since it was a gift from them,
if there's any people
back there doing it.
>> Paul Dolinsky: That's
a very good question.
It's hard to answer.
I'm not so sure I'm capable
of answering that question,
but you know, this
enduring relationship
of our countries regarding
those trees,
and I mean I don't know what
the total count is today,
but the 1912 shipment was 3,200
trees and there must be 32,000 trees
out there now in the
city of Washington,
and of course they're all
Japanese cherry blossoms.
And I don't know if there's
been a continual relationship
with Japan regarding
the exchange of trees,
but I do know that every
year, there's a very spiritual
and moving event for the cherry
blossom event itself and a visit
to the shrine there by the
Jefferson Memorial Bridge.
So I would say that that
at least is acknowledged
as the original planting by First
Lady Taft and Viscountess Chinda.
>> Mari Nakahara: Anne, would
you like to add something?
>> Paul Dolinsky: Yes?
>> Well, yes.
>> Paul Dolinsky: Sorry.
>> There's an ongoing
connection, to answer the question.
There are entities in Japan that
are interested in the ongoing
and making sure that the
connection keeps going.
I'll have to talk you
up on that [inaudible].
>> Paul Dolinsky: Thank you, Anne.
Yes, ma'am?
>> [Inaudible] both of
the cherry blossom trees.
>> Paul Dolinsky: Yes, ma'am?
>> Did I understand that
you have documentation
in all but one of the states?
>> Paul Dolinsky: Correct.
HALS is now represented
in 49 of the 50 states.
We're still fighting for --
I think it's either South
Dakota or North Dakota.
>> Okay, so if I was going
to visit Idaho, for example,
I could go online and find out where
in Idaho the witness trees were?
Is that correct?
>> Paul Dolinsky: Unfortunately
there are no witness trees in Idaho,
but you can go online at
the Library of Congress.
The witness tree project, it's
moving slowly, shall we say,
but it's popular in
the national parks.
Not so much in the states, but
they're starting to pick up on it.
But what I'd recommend is, well,
just I couldn't imagine going
to any state without checking
the HABS or HALS collection
at the Library of Congress
and you know,
it's extremely retentively
organized.
I mean they drive me crazy.
>> Mari Nakahara: I
just want [inaudible].
I wish I could show it here.
It's just simple.
Go to loc.com, Library of
Congress, loc.com/pictures.
Then you type in the
search box HABS or HALS.
>> Paul Dolinsky: Yeah,
or Burnside Sycamore.
It'll go right to the
drawings and photographs.
>> Mari Nakahara: Yes,
yes, then it'll find.
>> Paul Dolinsky: Yeah.
Any one of these, you
go right to them,
you can read the entire report.
>> So it's loc.gov
and then pictures?
>> Paul Dolinsky: I don't
think -- there might be.
They might be work
out that way, yes.
You get all the pictures
and all the written --
these, I'm just giving you,
of course, just a snippet
of the history, trying
to cover a few of them,
but some of these are
very large documents
and they're very interesting.
We had a young historian
work on them
that was a particular
Civil War buff,
so the Burnside Bridge
report is like 30 pages.
I know more than I ever wanted
to know about Ambrose Burnside.
>> And it does say,
does it not, whether
or not the tree is still there?
>> Paul Dolinsky: No, it does not.
>> Oh, my gosh.
Our record is of the year we did it.
It has subsequently been removed.
Those trees have been removed,
I apologize, some of them.
>> Oh, okay.
>> Paul Dolinsky: Yes, sir?
>> Just a point of information
on whether there's a
continuing relationship
between the US and Japan.
I know about two years ago, the US
State Department and the US embassy
in Tokyo donated, I
believe, a thousand trees
from the official tree of
Virginia, whatever it is.
I forget.
>> Paul Dolinsky: Tulip
poplar, I think.
>> Dogwood tree.
>> Paul Dolinsky: Dogwood?
Dogwood tree.
Okay, thanks.
>> Dogwood, maybe, yeah.
They donated that to Japan in the
spirit of friendship and as part
of the Tomodachi post-tsunami
efforts
to rekindle US/Japan relations.
>> Paul Dolinsky: Yeah.
>> And those trees have
been planted all over Japan.
>> Paul Dolinsky: Eliza
Scidmore would be proud.
Is that it?
[ Inaudible ]
Okay, one more.
>> I have actually read about a
town somewhere in Australia that,
for practical reasons,
they decided --
I can't remember if it
was [inaudible] addresses
or e-mail addresses to
the trees in the town --
>> Paul Dolinsky: Yes.
>> -- for [inaudible] purposes
and I wondered if, you know,
people started writing to
the addresses of trees.
>> Paul Dolinsky: Yeah,
I think that's brilliant.
I saw that article as well.
I thought it was really very, very
clever because it does, in some way,
very similar to what we're trying
to do with the witness trees
and somehow get people
to acknowledge trees,
but they have GPS points in all
the trees and each tree is numbered
and people, you know, write the
story or tell if there's a problem.
They keep it sort of -- they
keep track of it that way.
I did see that as well.
>> I'm just curious if you
had thought of doing something
like that as public promotion.
I mean I'm sure they'll be
all numbered and tracked, too.
>> Paul Dolinsky: Well, you know,
I think there would be a great app
on a phone, like a witness tree
app, that you would, you know,
pull up on your phone and click
Washington, DC and you click
and it takes you to the Library,
it takes you to the location,
so let's talk about that.
We could make some money on that.
>> Mari Nakahara: Well, thank
you very much and [inaudible].
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.